on this episode we talk about managing
your time YouTube optimization and being
a dad
[Music]
you ask
ah
this is
ask Gary B
[Music]
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 2 28 of the ask gary
vee show we are rolling here it is a
Thursday in New York City it is gorgeous
outside one of you sent me this t-shirt
thank you found in my closet
I am very focused tonight is the season
is on the line
I know a lot of people like you can't
have the season online after two games I
understand the seasons on the line Jets
have to win tonight in Buffalo
I hate Rex Ryan I hate Buffalo Bills I
hate the town of Buffalo tonight
I hate Chris Sacca who's a Buffalo Bills
fan Jamal Henderson Buffalo Bills fan uh
Zack Kline Buffalo Bills fan Kim Kim Kim
Garcia Buffalo Bills fan I hate all
these people India I know you are I know
you're um how you doing good good good
mica shows the Simon epic by the way I
really thought I did as well as I could
not interrupting Simon and still I'm
getting - no more guests ever again in
the Vayner show here I don't the meter
shows I'm asking Little India that was
remark that was as good as it's gonna
get I was really holding back and yet
still people like Simon was on Gary show
but you'd never know cuz he listened
really that's insane I thought I did a
great job but you know whatever all
right what's the first question I'm
ready why are we doing so many bad music
I'm kidding I'm kidding
hey yeah this is Yannick from pond do
you have any thoughts about recent
YouTube monetization changes they think
their competitors will benefit from that
do you have any names which companies we
should look out for which platforms like
YouTube we should look out for thank you
Gary
so what's the punchline uh through this
I I'm not super sure Dino they went to
subscription stuff are they like making
less ads does anybody know the context
of this I know you guys probably assumed
I know but I'm not paying attention
telly they're making
the monetization on YouTube there they
have a algorithm to say which videos
they can monetize in which they do so
they can and they're making it less
strict it was kind of fuzzy on what they
can monitor what you tube created and
monetizing mathematic and based on IP
and stuff of that nature is your
constant as a cursing too lowbrow got it
Yanik I think look look this happens
forever uh you ever send something out
of anybody in this world this is I'm
gonna give a very good answer that
doesn't answer the question I just got
the context you know I don't you know
there's I'm gonna give you a really good
[ __ ] answer I'm really fired up now
because I'm gonna level this up and I'm
gonna bury leveled up mentality for the
show anybody who's watching the show
that is tying their economics into a
platform that is privately held is
making a massive mistake for all the
people that made all their money on
google optimization this is back in a
day like where else are we going to go
when Google changes the algorithm and
they take down lowbrow it's the same
game the platform's have their users
interests in mind people come along and
try to extract value that have their
best interest in mind the platform's
have big scale and opportunity people
want to make money off of that as people
want to make money off of that they look
for angles shortcuts lowest common
denominator
you know arbitrage they look for their
move and so whether it was affiliate
marketing and Adsense AdWords arbitrage
Commission Junction YouTube the Facebook
pages there's always these moments where
you know there's the ebb and flow the
seesaw of like the cat and mouse game of
the people that produce content on these
platforms MySpace this is just history
this is been the last 20 years of the
Internet what happens is the platform
will make a macro decision that's in the
best interest of the end users at scale
and it will hurt the people that been
hacking the system slideshows on the
internet that allow those advertisers to
make money those media companies make
more money gets advertisers that sat in
the middle and didn't care about the
quality this is a quality quantity game
that plays itself out so your honor
here's what I would say and for
everybody else that's watching whether
it is snapchat or Instagram or Facebook
or Twitter or YouTube or podcasting
diversify your world you need to be
everywhere and creating brand and scale
everywhere that you're capable of and if
you're not well then maybe you don't
deserve to make as much but relying
solely on the revenue of one platform is
a humongous mistake especially when that
platform is a private business that is
going to make the decisions for that
platform
I loved everybody when the Facebook
algorithm changes organic reach dropped
and they were trying to drive their ad
revenue up that all you had real puffy
chests and saying well we're going to go
elsewhere how'd that work out for you
Rick I've decided I'm gonna I'm going
I'm quadrupling down on the Rick thing
by the way I'm basically have decided to
make Rick my enemy eventually we're
gonna eventually entries gonna draw Rick
he's gonna wear a tie we're gonna
[ __ ] kill Rick yeah Rick is gonna be
huge
Rick is gonna be my Mickey Mouse Dave hi
Gary yeah hey Gary its Dave co-founder
wino in Zurich I'm here with the theme
we're interested about the future of
Finance and FinTech it's been getting a
lot of VC money and interest from the
media you talk about investing in money
as an entrepreneur we'd really like to
hear your view on what is the future of
banking or finance
that's a great question data thank you
and team look I think thin tech has been
hot for a very long time and continues
to be in through web 1.0 and web 2.0 and
social web and today fin tech is always
an opportunity there's so much sass
opportunity there's so much inefficiency
in the banking and financial worlds
based on people at scale and I think
technology look I think of FinTech the
same way I think of everything else
uber Airbnb Amazon they are the absolute
previews not anomalies they happen to
get to the book industry the black car
service and hotelling so what do I think
I think venmo our mentor all these
things have been chipping away and
creating billion-dollar eggs and
opportunities within FinTech and because
finance and money transferring and our
personal relationships with money
FinTech is an incredible place it's been
a place that I've never been very
passionate about I've never really gone
after that I tend to like consumer
behaviors that are more kind of just
just not around money I guess really
escapism entertainment communication not
around finances but I think it's an
extremely fertile ground and one of the
core pillars of who we are as human
beings and I think that like everything
in the world technology will eat it up
change it spit it out create
billionaires crush fortunes create new
ones and I think the financial sector is
no exception especially when you take it
to the most macro levels which is like
cryptocurrency they're just like that's
arbitrage and the money itself I mean
the enormous opportunity in FinTech just
ironically the reason you don't hear
much for me is I'm not deeply educated
in it because I haven't spent time
paying attention to it it's just not one
of the areas that I'm passionate about
but the thesis of opportunity is
enormous yeah I think so again this is a
favorite question of all time wow that's
a big statement well look stop hyping me
up earnest okay my name is earnest comer
I'm a dad and I'm wondering was one of
the biggest life events
or especially mr. Halden due to your
commitment to the work huh
and how did you overcome thanks man
you know earnest personal that was
remarkable and about as adorable as it
gets
iris you know I haven't missed anything
I'd miss some some you know school plays
and and I haven't missed any no birth I
would never miss a birthday there hasn't
been a signature event there seven and
four there hasn't been you know Xander's
bris you know like I'm not miss like
that would be that'd be insane to me to
miss anything of that nature um I would
you know I I guess we all have different
scale of what's important there's dads
out there who would never in the world
miss a baseball game of their son ever I
would I just don't think the fifth game
in a season for Xander if something that
is remarkable for me and Xander my
family's life is coming that place I
wouldn't miss Sanders fifth baseball
game for a big meeting or a new client
when I miss it for the opportunity to
close a 78 million dollar deal for our
family yes I would I just I just would
and and I know one would say well that's
money like yeah but but would I miss
Xander's championship game after he
played baseball every day of his life
for nine years and it was his number one
passion in the world to close a 78
million dollar deal matter no it's
closer
I wouldn't say definitely not I just
don't know I mean I don't know I first
of all Santa was 13 Xander at 13 after
watching all my business YouTube videos
might want me to I don't know
here's what I would say earnest and
everybody else first and foremost I
would never judge anybody else's
parenting or process I've the greatest
relationships in the world my parents
and I have a lot of things that were
done differently than others and I think
we all have but knock on wood I think is
a far more interesting question maybe
five to seven years from now so far I'm
rolling there's been nothing even
remotely intense that I can think of
that I've missed
they've been micro little play this play
that you know last day of school like a
teacher conference yeah there's been a
couple little things that are like
lightweight they're also very very young
right now but so far nothing
I haven't had to pick everything that I
felt I've missed a lot of business
things that I that are solid business
things that I've missed because I wanted
to be there for the first day of school
or you know or the taught Shabbat day
that's the one time Xander gets to do
that and in you know the little temple
Israel school that he went to like their
single little things like that but it's
weighing things it's when things and I'm
not crippled by the current state of
political correctness of how you parent
because news alert my friends it's going
to be different in 15 years and it was
different 15 years ago yes thank you
touch about cute Rachel hey Gary Rachel
here love the show so my question today
is do you recommend building a personal
brand even if you're a behind-the-scenes
player Rachel it's a great question I
would say absolutely let me get an
example if you're behind-the-scenes
player wouldn't you want to be behind
the scenes of somebody that you believe
is the greatest in the world and if you
are building your personal brand around
I'm an unbelievable number two or number
four unbelievable admin or an
unbelievable I don't want to be out
there but I want to support the people I
believe in the most those people are
going to be looking for those people and
so you might build the brand as an
incredible human infrastructure player
for somebody who's the greatest and that
would be then great for you if you were
the number one admin to the most
successful person in the world you're
and the nicest I mean I don't wanna make
this just about money there's always a
better situation potentially and you
want to give yourself that best
opportunity so building personal brand
only speaks my friends to opportunity if
you're good at and you're articulating
your truth and you have the goods to
back it up all being out there and
people get so caught up in semantics of
hate the world personal brand like don't
get caught up in the Sania semantics
having exposure that creates opportunity
is a good idea
period
packs all up in it
hey Gary Zack here question referring
back to episode 156 when preparing
employees for leadership how do you
foster leadership with rising stars or
unsung heroes thanks for everything you
do appreciate it
Zack I think this is a really
interesting question you know what's
really funny to me is it's a funny where
my brain goes on this one which is
actions Trump everything meaning you
prepare them by giving them
opportunities to show that they can I
think one of the things that I'm most
proud of is for the intensity that I
come with for as much as I want to
happen I would tell you that if you
audited everybody here in this room and
everybody the 700 people across five
offices across here it is stunning how
little I micromanage if you want to
foster leadership you have to put people
in a position to be leaders
I don't box you in I don't box Garrett
in I critique when I give him the room
to win or lose if he loses in the game
he's playing I'll articulate what the
shortcomings were what the opportunities
are so I think leadership is only
accomplished or limit phrase the
prepping of something is only
accomplished when you actually do this
is where I get really mad about
entrepreneurs school entrepreneur school
is like reading about push-ups like you
know dunk wants a challenge me into some
crazy weight thing of like who can bench
more whatever you're up to and so what's
the preparation for that I can't read
about bench press technique I gotta go
do it you got to put in the work I've
been working out every day since then
done because not I'm getting more prep
now he may have more natural talent he
just might be stronger he's definitely
much younger and should in theory win
this but he won't because I'll prepare
him and so that's the punchline prep and
so how they're an unsung hero whether
they're the most shining star I I always
worry a veiner that people think the
people that PR themselves or the most
loud and charismatic are the ones that
are gonna get the opportunities and I've
been really enjoying building Vayner
over the last five years especially the
last two years because the smartest
people here are like hey wait a minute
look at this person winning and they
don't even really am in Iraq with Gary I
mean heard of that person like that's
the role and responsibility I have that
I'm not just pandering to the easiest
move and so you give people opportunity
some are loud about it I got this others
just quietly and go and do it but here's
the punchline whether you're like me and
you talk a ton of [ __ ] and you back at
the [ __ ] up every [ __ ] time that's a
win or you say nothing but you back at
the [ __ ] up every time it's the second
part that matters so put those people in
a position to succeed and then watch if
they're doing it call their bluff give
them a shot push them harder than they
think that they can do believe in them
more than they believe in themselves and
create the framework and the
opportunities to do that understand it
is in your upside as a leader for them
to fail and you figure out if they can
do it versus that task being done
correctly I prefer that we lose a client
lose a client money out of my pocket but
I learn something about the leaders that
I'm thinking about going to battle with
versus me micromanaging it never
learning about their opportunity as
leaders and then getting the client for
two more years
that's called scale that's called
auditing that's called how you build
stuff it's a lot of magic in this
episode said it well I'm fast prediction
of the day the Jets go into Buffalo and
win and they win solidly 22:7 Jets
question of the day for you what does
this could be up other Tyler well no no
there's no time were morning there's my
Jets prediction so we have to work we
have to not worry about dailyvee and get
this up ASAP good question of the day
what's your Jets prediction if anybody
nails the score they got a time stamp
before the game actually started
anything after kickoff doesn't count
because then you can watch the cadence
of the game if you predict the score I'm
flying you to New York you'll be you
here you'll be right here
what's that well yeah he's gonna get it
up in three hours from now and they'll
be three you know the hardest chord
maniacs that actually watch it what's
that
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]